[Musique]
alors on est en route vers des élections
au québec vous savez évidemment
fin de la session demain à québec j'en
profite pour parler ce soir à gabriel
nadeau dubois nous recevions hier le
chef du parti québécois monsieur nadeau
dubois bonsoir bonsoir monsieur roy un
petit mot rapide quand même ça vient
d'arriver à québec on met sur pause ce
projet de loi sur l'élargissement de
l'aide à mourir il ya quelque chose de
rafraîchissant pour les téléspectateurs
pour les gens qui regardent son devoir
que les parties peuvent quand même
parfois travailler tous ensemble
quand les enjeux sont d'un sérieux comme
celui-là quand il s'agit de la vie ou de
la mort des québécois et des québécoises
parce que quand on parle d'aidé médicale
à mourir quand même c'est de ça dont il
s'agit je pense que c'est bien oui qu'on
soit capable de travailler ensemble on
aurait tous voulu être capable d'adopter
ce projet de loi là avant la fin de la
session mais la paire option sans ré
était de travailler à la va-vite de
tourner les coins ronds donc on serait
lié à l'évidence qui est qu'il va
falloir prendre un peu plus de temps
avant d'élargir la demie discale à
mourir au québec et pourquoi pas si on
veut bien faire les choses voilà très
bien
le débat sur la souveraineté qui a été
relancée d'abord il faut faut le mettre
en contexte si monsieur legault quand il
a parlé de la louisiane la survie du
peuple québécois et la sas a relancé les
questions mais d'accord sur fédéral nous
donne pas les pouvoirs est ce que vous
allez vous relancer dans une dans une
bataille sur la souveraineté vous
monsieur nadeau dubois êtes vous comme à
la cac une coalition entre des
fédéralistes des souverainistes vous
êtes clairement souverainistes ou le
mans québec solidaire depuis sa
fondation est un parti indépendantiste
ça ne pas changer ça changera pas moi ce
que je retiens des deux dernières
semaines c'est à quel point françois
legault a sorti de son chapeau
ce spectre de la louisianisation du
québec je veux dire on est en pleine
crise de l'inflation c'est la pire
depuis 30 ans les gens sont pris à la
gorge la classe moyenne est rendu dans
les banques alimentaires il ya une crise
climatique qui nous pend au bout du nez
il ya une crise du logement qui met des
familles à la rue et françois le groupe
décide de lancer sa campagne électorale
sur le thème de l'immigration et des
signes religieux le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
priorités parce que moi je sais ce dont
les gens me parlent l'aller j'adore je
faisais pourquoi il par des signes
religieux c'est parce que vous faites le
lien de l'arrivée de bernard drainville
et de ceux des bols de la charia et et
parce que monsieur legault lui-même été
très clair il le dit je demande un
mandat fort pour aller défendre ma loi
sur les signes religieux dans les
prochaines années nous aussi on va
demander un mandat fort mais ça va pour
pour être pas ce ne sera pas pour parler
des angelots ça va pas parler de crise
du coût de la vie de crise du logement
le crise climatique mais comment ça
s'incarne l'indépendance dans votre
parti comment ça se passe que vous en
parlez jamais on a l'impression commence
à 50 c'est que vous dites oui ce sacre
acquis mais on n'a pas pu quoi ya pas de
démarche est pas de propositions y
auriez même si c'est faux c'est dans
toutes nos plateformes électorales
depuis notre fondation pour nous les
dépendances d'un projet de société
c'est pas un projet de re peas est pas
un projet tourné vers le passé c'est un
projet tourné vers l'avenir pour nous
les dépendances est aussi une occasion
de se réconcilier avec les premières
nations québec une occasion historique
de fonder un nouvel état dans un
dialogue de nation à nation avec les
peuples autochtones ça a toujours été ça
notre vision de l'indépendance et oui
elle est profondément différente de la
vision du parti québécois elle est
profondément différentes d'abord proposé
un référendum de l'indépendance du
québec ce qu'on propose depuis 15 ans la
même chose monsieur roy il faut lire
notre programme vous lisant on propose
la création sa part rapport d'une
assemblée constituante qui donnerait au
peuple québécois les clés de ce projet
là pour définir lui-même un projet
d'indépendance qu'ils soient différents
puits qui soit un projet de société pour
un projet tourné
vers l'arrière ou un projet qui pointe
du doigt les immigrants en les accusant
par exemple d'être une menace à la
survie de la nation québécoise nous
c'est pas comme ça qu'on veut faire de
la politique c'est sur ce qu'on fait
mais monsieur vous avez totalement le
droit d'un trait des pans entiers c'est
de choisir la voie vous voulez ce que je
vous jure ce que je vous dis c'est que
vous en parlait dans les faits dans le
discours politique vous en parlait pas
beaucoup c'est ce que je vais vous dire
mes pires voilà c'est un fait ben c'est
un fait avec lequel je suis en désaccord
mon collègue seul zanetti a déposé cette
session si par exemple un projet de loi
pour abolir le serment de l'arrêt on est
entré peut-être si le parti libéral du
québec non son consentement de l'adopter
à l'assemblée nationale vous savez
monsieur roy c'est pas parce qu'on n'est
pas péquiste qu'on n'est pas
indépendantiste c'est pas parce qu'on ne
parle pas du québec comme
l'establishment indépendantiste le fait
depuis 95 qu'on n'en parle pas on en
parle différemment parce qu'on veut
reconstruire ce projet là sur des bases
différentes notamment et c'est pas un
détail mais pas du tout sur des bases
égalitaires avec les premières nations
du québec avec qui on partage le
territoire québécois c'est sûr mais ne
proposant pas un référendum vous bloquez
pas dans une stratégie qui ferait peur à
des gens qui ne veulent pas et vous on
va s'entendre là-dessus la plupart des
québécois actuellement ne veulent pas de
débat référendaire on s'entend moi je
pense que le débat dont les québécois
sont tannés la cdu débats stériles entre
le vieux projet d'indépendance et la
vieille manière de s'y opposer la
manière libérale qu'on constate
d'ailleurs dans toute sa splendeur
depuis les derniers jours parce que ce
qui était frappant chez monsieur de
révéler madame sans cela c'est qu'ils ne
veulent plus se définir comme
souverainiste puis c'est leur droit mais
il ya des militants de québec solidaire
et que je connais la montreal des jeunes
et qui ne se définissent absolument pas
comme indépendantiste mais qui veulent
militer dans votre partie vous leur
dites il ya de la place aussi pour les
fédéralistes
progressistes dans mon parti québec
solidaire c'est c'est re parti
indépendantiste notre programme il est
classé cette question leur plateforme
électorale
également il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté chez
nous mais notre projet il est différent
parce qu'on veut le réinventer on veut
sortir de la vieille manière d'en parler
qui est un échec monsieur roy si ça
avait fonctionné la recette du parti
québécois on le saurait et ça ne peut
pas fonctionner sur des duos dubois la
campagne quel sera le thème qui va
dominer quand vous regardez le faim ou
l' inflation vous en avait parlé est ce
convoi selon vous vraiment parler de
climat en france campagne présidentielle
complète le le côté du climat la crise
climatique n'a eu à peu près pas fait
partie des débats moi je pense qu'on n'a
pas le choix on a une responsabilité
comme les deux politiques en 2022 de
faire de la question environnementale de
la question climatique
un sujet au coeur de la prochaine
campagne électorale le prochain mandat
2022 ou 2026 c'est le dernier c'est le
dernier que nous avons pour relever le
défi climatique
moi je m'attends à ce que tous les
partis politiques fassent de cet enjeu
là un enjeu prioritaire je relance
l'invitation à françois legault
d'accepter un débat des chefs sur la
question climatique c'est notre
responsabilité de traiter cet enjeu là
avec tout le sérieux qu'il mérite et
nous en aurons un plan on aura le plan
le plus ambitieux et le plus crédible
sur la question des changements
climatiques et le plus réaliste il sera
chiffré il sera détaillé et moi j'ai
hâte d'en débattre avec françois legault
encore faut-il qu'ils acceptent dans des
maps et qu'ils arrêtent de se défiler
sinon vous avez bien raison le coût de
la vie ont pourront contourner cet enjeu
là et nous avons à lonay québec soldats
françois legault dans les dernières
semaines sans relâche sur cette question
là les québécois et québécoises
s'attendent à des propositions concrètes
et structurantes parce que la crise de
l'inflation à disparaître au mois
d'octobre au mois de novembre on est
pris là dedans pour de nombreux mois il
faut des solutions pour aider les
familles du québec à passer au travers
on aura nous à québec soldats les
propositions pour les gens et ça va être
pas mal plus on lira qu'un gérer ou
trois mois comme comme ça le premier de
françois legault gabriel nadeau-dubois
merci beaucoup chef parlementaire de
québec solidaire à bientôt merci
monsieur roy pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit